oui je suis pas présenté Stéphane reg ah
le fils de Serge oui alors ça ah oui
d'accord d'accord non non je parlons
d'autre chose vous avez des enfants oui
deux de ah ben s je n pas oui non j'ai
rien
[Musique]
dit tu es
venu en ce
monde à
l'envers toi tout
nu au milieu de
l'hiver parmi ces
gens cette vie que tu n'as pas
choisi tacher le sang et meurt déjà tu
as
sourir je
t'aimee
ma
fille et tu ne le
[Musique]
sais moi qui
jouais à la grande
personne pas pour de
V comme une pH
tu m'as donné en issant la force de
vieillir d'aimer les heurs et les ans
qui te verront
grandir je
t'aime ma
fille et tu ne le
sais
tu m'as
livraé sans aucun
maquillage tout est
sacr tes chansons tes
images châau
branlant qui ne vient pas même à mes
genoux tu m'as aidé en tombant à me
tenir
debout je
t'aime ma
fille et tu ne le sa
[Musique]
pas je me fais
fort si tu me tiens la
main de
t'emmener jusqu'au bout du chemin
ou quelqu'un
d'autre autrement te prendras dans ses
bras si je te quitte en pleurant tu ne
le verra
pas je
t'aime
ma
fille je
t'aime et tu ne le
sais
[Musique]
pas bien